this is san marcos texas over a century
ago
the united states fish commission dug a
well plunging 188 feet into the earth
right at the heart of the city and when
they did water rushed to the surface
at thousands of gallons a minute
flushing out dozens of undiscovered
creatures from the depths below
these animals had never seen the surface
nor would they
because all of them were blind perhaps
the strangest looking animal in this
catch was a species dubbed uracia
rathbuni
now known as the texas blind salamander
upon discovery herbitologist leonhard
steinager described them
as such these animals by want of
external
eyes and their white color had once
proclaimed themselves
as cave dwellers but their extraordinary
proportions
suggest unusual conditions of life which
alone can have produced such profound
differences
these unusual conditions are contained
to a specific 26-mile stretch of caves
in the edwards aquifer an extensive
underground layer of rocks
it's the only place in the world this
species of salamander has ever been
recorded
so how did these caves create the
profound differences in these
salamanders appearance
in other words how did they end up
looking so weird
to answer this question we have to go
back in time way back
take the dates with a grain of salt but
we think that this
this group split off from its
most recent common ancestor probably
around
somewhere between 10 and 15 million
years ago and geologists estimate that
the aquifer had been hundreds of
millions of years in the making
during the jurassic period some 200
million years ago
the area was occasionally covered in
shallow oceans
but when the area was dry and exposed to
air the rocks were eroded by weather to
make porous caverns
eventually a shallow basin of water and
sediment covered the land
then that basin dried up but rainfall
continued to eat away at the earth
to create the deep fissures and caverns
inside the aquifer
scientists like devitt think that as the
climate became more arid
some salamanders crawled beneath the
surface seeking refuge in the cool and
stable environment of the edwards
aquifer
and over the course of millions of years
these salamanders adapted to the aquatic
subterranean caves
by evolving certain features like blood
red gills outside of their body
while losing others like their eyes
living in complete darkness alongside
prey that was also blind
the salamanders simply didn't need to
see and energy used for sight would only
be wasted
today only two small black dots just
under the skin
remain as evidence of eyes past those
dots
likely only detect if it's light or dark
out
this use it or lose it type of evolution
also applies to their silvery white skin
skin pigmentation usually protects
animals from the sun's uv light
and serves as camouflage from predators
but both of those are non-issues for the
blind salamanders
who don't have to worry about the sun or
predators
these small spindly salamanders are at
the top of the food chain in this
ecosystem
feeding on various crustaceans like
shrimp and even though they can go
months without eating
when a potential snack does swim by
several features help them capture their
prey
one is a special adaptation similar to
the lateral line found in fish
which detects vibrations in the water
the salamander's sensory cells respond
to changes in water movement and
pressure letting them know what
direction and how fast
their meal is moving another helpful
feature is their large head
which fits 10 to 15 percent more teeth
than surface salamanders
more teeth means a deadlier bite which
is crucial if you come by prey
only a few times a year all of those
things are characteristics that help you
survive in a very very challenging
environment
so that's why they look the way that
they do fenoglio is one of the lucky few
who's seen these elusive salamanders up
close
last year his team at the san antonio
zoo bred texas blind salamanders for the
first time in a lab
and they've repeated their success four
more times they're aiming to protect the
species from
extinction since the salamanders have
been endangered since 1967
two main things threaten the texas
salamander's survival
the first is contamination from
wastewater runoff
this is a big issue because the edwards
aquifer is a so-called karst aquifer
which means it's made of soluble rock
like limestone any pollution on the
surface
can rapidly seep into and contaminate
groundwater
wastewater typically holds tons of
nutrients which fuels the growth of
algae
when the algae decompose this process
sucks
oxygen from the water leaving less
oxygen for our sensitive salamanders
the second threat is a loss of habitat
this happens when rainfall cannot
adequately replenish the water that
people take
and this threat is real the aquifer
serves several cities
including san antonio one of the fastest
growing cities in the nation
and the largest city in the country that
relies entirely on an aquifer for its
water
so while being able to breed the
salamanders is a good first step towards
one day building up colonies
the animal may be confined to labs if
they have no home to return to
you know in areas where there's been you
know hundreds of feet of
groundwater depletion we've almost
already almost certainly already lost
species to that and we just don't know
about it because we're still
describing new species from the aquifer
all the time
devitt's team is using new tools to suss
out blind salamander populations
such as a method that analyzes water
samples for traces of the animal's dna
he and his collaborator recently
discovered four new related species in
the aquifer
for now scientists say that these
salamanders can hang in there as long as
the only home they've ever known
stays constant but that's an increasing
challenge as more people move to the
[Music]
area